[Musique]
ya de l'amour dans l'équipe 1 s'est bien
fait de l'amour y avait de l'amour
alala septembre c'est parce qu'on on a
découvert mais finissez vos phrases
parce que parce qu'on est là c'est assez
grave la jolie on a découvert pendant ce
prime n'a découvert vos talents
d'animatrice
mais il ya une année il ya plutôt une
révélation qui a été fait pendant ce
prime qui est très grave a pas gardé
mais c'était bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai donc décidé de visionner ce
week-end image par image ce qui s'était
passé lors de ce fameux jeu et boiboite
de noël j'ai même appelé à l'aide de mon
ami jean luc lemoine vous récupérez
l'épreuve pendant les coupures pub
moi si je veux dénoncer quelqu'un savait
que c'est moche moche et c'est pas beau
nom mais calmez vous on a récupéré
toutes les preuves pendant les coupures
pub et géo montré dans un instant le
résumé des événements minute par minute
hier et je voulais c'est très très grave
ce qui s'est passé vous déciderez la
sanction et vous jugerez si vous êtes
choqués ou pas par ce café
capucine on l'est déjà sans déconner
vous allez voir la séquence et en plus
il y a quelqu'un il ya un complice et on
ne sait pas qui est ce complice et
j'espère qu'elle nous dira de qu'il
s'agisse ici à lanton tous libres vous
verrez des images il ya un moment et
nous sommes en direct soir direct avec
nos invités sabrina ouazani et sur une
commandeur l'embarras du choix
en allongeant un instant il ya camille
combal qui va venir des besoins il aura
bien sûr d'huisne en pense quoi ton
frère je suis souvent venu sur ce
plateau là on vit un moment glaçant
savait que les très graves c'est très
grave
oui gravats laissés jérôme depuis très
longtemps si vous nous rejoignez en
direct sur ces huit ont reparlé du prime
de capucine à naves ce prime avait été
obtenu lors d'un jeu avec des boîtes et
pendant la pub
tout le monde était choqué ah ouais
ouais
il était même des listes choqué non mais
je rigole mais je vous jure que je suis
hyper v ah ouais je vais vous expliquer
donc on a fait toute la reconstitution
de ce jeu les bois boîte de noël
matthieu delormeau
le pauvre a perdu son prime le point un
pont de pomas mathieu 6 s y voilà je le
dis j'ai appelé mon ami jean luc lemoine
on va vous vers le résumé des événements
minute par minute
vous voyez bien ce qui s'est passé et
capucine harkis qui rigolent en plus
agacée oui parce que je vous allez voir
vous allez voir déjà que vous sachiez
j'avais demandé aux chroniqueurs de
choisir leur boîte pendant la pub pour
gagner du temps donc capucine avait
choisi la boîte numéro 2 regardez merci
à menacer les chéris ce que je propose
c'est vous choisissez les boîtes on se
retrouve dans un instant et vous allez
découvrir le cadeau de chacun a tout de
suite sur cv
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
ouais
capucine a appris la boîte de la miette
procès pris la 2 bat parce que j'avais
en mettront de la baisse était moins
cher par bonnaire d'accord je vais
trouver un petit peu insolente oui un
jérôme saison chief pur bonheur c'est le
deux et c'est l'essai sabrina
généralement quand on fait une bêtise on
se fait tout petit c'est vrai on fait
profil bas quoi voilà mais vous
connaissez l'histoire non avant vous
allez voir mes histoires je vous allez
moi je vous jure géré horrible revue
revu les images
une horreur une horreur mais surtout que
tu es ma boîte que je voulais oui c'est
encore plus grands pas capucine où vous
avez choisi la boîte 2 et après avoir
choisi la boîte de capucine reçoit un
mystérieux sms regarde
je vous hais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui les images vous les voyez comme moi
c'est dramatique
non mais qu'il se calme comme un scanner
vous êtes choqués giron suis assez
choqué parce que je commence à réaliser
avec une émission familiale où les gens
membres
il ya des enfants alors qu'y avait-il
décrit sur ce sms
on ne sait pas on le saura peut-être
jamais en tout cas il va le bouleverser
le reste du jeu regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les actuaires l'esab la mise et touche
pas
[Musique]
vous avez vu donc il check les numéros
de boîte
on l'a vu aussi a priori tout d'un coup
la boîte de l'intéressent plus du tout
excuser moi est-ce que je peux changer
plat ça me dégoûte ne prenez pas de mois
sans les prévenir mais non merci j'ai
pas envie de courir merci jean luc
d'ailleurs pour toutes les images merci
jean lui donc la boîte de l'intéressé
plus du tout non et mathieu je sais que
prenait cette affaire au sérieux
alors non mais sans déconner regardez
bien elle avait qu'une seule idée en
tête s'était changé de boîte
alors pourquoi une telle que de la cité
comprenez pugnacité
tout d'abord parce que je rappelle à
tous l'enjeu des bois bois un prime time
sur ces 8
donc elles lâchaient rien et on à la
suite de la faire regardez deuxième
tentative des changes de moyenne
[Musique]
comment tu sais pas d'ouvrir assez
dégueulasse pas c'est dégueulasse sonar
et on aura la réaction de gilles verdez
on a on l'a mis au courant avant nous
fasse une réaction il nous a envoyé une
vidéo
profitez de la précarité mentale d'une
vieille personne je vous jure
aujourd'hui mais je vous jure
alors j'adore capucine remettra rien en
commun vous mais non pas mais je dormais
vous a rien à voir et c'est vrai vous
n'êtes pas dans l'histoire où je
comprends pas une forme de mépris
qualités mentales
non mais je déteste la tricherie jamais
vraiment beinheim elle sait que je me
suis je peux moins brouillée quelqu'un
je déteste ça alors elle les sciences la
boîte
ça y est alors donc vous réussissez à
récupérer la boîte prévue mais moi ce
sont qui sera un truc louche un truc pas
net et je vient la voir
et regardez là
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais si tu me ressembles
je vais vous dénoncez c'est là une manne
à la porte bonheur tient la scène à deux
maintenant c'est l'oeil
mathieu pour l'instant jusqu'à présent
que vous pensez de cette affaire non
mais en vrai de vrai jeu mais aussi en
même temps je t'adore mais en vrai de
res sur connexes et c'est curieux alors
comble du l'islam affirme qu'elle est
innocent et qu'elle n'a rien fait alors
et finale évidemment je la fais je fais
confiance que je les aime bien mais
c'était sans savoir que vous aviez une
complice dans ce stratagème
machiavélique parution
vous avez
c'est la mi temps
m
[Musique]
j'en crois pas mes yeux
non mais mathieu d'autant que si ç'avait
été une vanne vous auriez payé par le
dire alors que vous avez gardé de secret
quand même toutes les deux donc elle a
eu son prime a atteint sont pas une
belle gentille et non mais attendez
attendez
elle a eu son prime elle a fait son
prime alors que c'était isabelle qui
devait le faire à la base et shihri
peut-être mathieu s'il avait changé les
boîtes en tout cas ce n'était pas
capucines enfin moi les chéris je vais
manger des merguez dimanche à lille
dijon et je sais même pas manger les
appels appétit non mais sans déconner
c'est plus que vous en pensez mais ce
qui sur twitter déjà ghamdi j'épluche
des choses on serait passé si on peut
révéler quelque chose c'est que la
justice aille a même pas cinq minutes à
la pause publicitaire s'est tenue la
voir en demandant est ce qu'elle a reçu
un sms
oui droit dans les yeux a dit non l'om
bien mais ça incroyable mais c'est par
vous remercier l'école nrj 12 je
m'exprime connaissent pas est ce que
vous êtes choqués valérie franchement
alors que la vérité je suis choquée mais
en même temps je peux comprendre qu'elle
avait une envie tellement folle mais
voilà mais moi ce qui m'intéresse
maintenant c'est de savoir qui a envoyé
le sms qu'elle a donc quelqu'un qui a
envoyé un message pour lui dire
attention tu n'as pas la bonne voie il
ya une affaire dans la sphère dans les
essais taupont val introduit le prouvera
la tombe malade gesticule ça va être un
fils de à mon avis non mais c'est normal
cindy dit franchement mais là plus est
ce que c'est ce que vous êtes très
franchement je suis offusqué jamais dit
la vérité mais je sais pas ce qui vous
arrive
d'accord la titre la tricherie et c'est
une possibilité et forcer le destin
c'en est une autre alors at elle forcer
le destin pour ensuite se prévaloir
auprès de cyril c'est une vraie question
[Rires]
mais c'est pas une honte
c'est pas toujours de et là c'est la
phrase que j'ai compris il arrive et
benjamin castaldi dit la vérité
honnêtement c'est pas bien c'est pas
bien d'avoir fait ça
j'aimerais voir qu'ils essaient de tous
les temps ça c'est très inquiétant
inquiétant à dire que tous les jeux de
boîtes qu'on a fait dans cette émission
on n'a rien gagné mais j'ai gagné des
produits de beauté de la mer d'arabie a
mais je vous jure moi je laisse mon
staff je ne sais pas ah oui je ne sais
pas ce cadre il valait genou droit il ya
un vrai problème c'est vrai que j'ai
envie c'est horrible je pense que ça
aurait dû être là que matthieu delormeau
attendez vous devriez choqué ben oui ça
me choque parce que ce qui est terrible
c'est que depuis le début on se dit que
capucine pour la tous pris sous notre
protection se dit elle est fragile et un
peu naïve et pas naïve du tout anormal
du tout c'est mata hari la fille non
mais c'est vrai alors mathieu vous
finirez 1 parce que je me sens vraiment
live on l'a perdu jean-mi belge en
restant franchement je veux pas pouvoir
faire caca pendant quinze jours on est
tous victimes parce que nous on fait ça
honnêtement les jeux ont été les mots
voilés figaro est en fait il ya des gens
qui répondent et qui triche à chaque
fois pareil je chéris la vérité je suis
un petit peu choqué parce que comme dit
le grand auteur bruno masure la télé
rend fou et visiblement elle a un peu
rendu ses vrais parents du capitole
après la télé c'est que la télé et ça a
permis surtout l'émergence de quelqu'un
de bien vendredi donc je suis un peu
choqué mais pas trop vous allez voir
l'émergence vous allez voir les maires
de bien plus agathe comme toute la
france je suis abasourdi évidemment mais
mais après en visionnant du coup les ces
images odieuses on a quand même vu que
isabelle était soulagé de ne pas avoir
cette boîte aux lettres
ben nous mais j'avoue que je surpris
parce qu'il faut pas que la télé ne pas
se perdre tes valeurs qu a pu aller les
gens l'aiment pour son innocence
notamment parce que c'est la petite
soeur qu'on aime tous parce qu'elle a un
peu fofolle et parce que voilà et en
fait on découvre effectivement une
personne assez machiavélique qui est
même prêt à tout y compris à corrompre
une personne âgée pour avoir une non
mais voilà bon pour pour donc ouais
j'avoue que il ya ça qui me choque alors
apprécions très honnête je pense pas
qu'il serait forcément revenu et les
échanges de bois qui devrait lever bon
peu importe mais je reconnais que je
suis surpris voilà par toi et surpris
qu'ils aient une taupe
oui est ce que voulait être choqué ouais
ce que vous voulez voir la racaille albi
là est la réaction de capucine revoir la
réaction capucine quand elle sait
qu'elle a gagné le prime et là vous
allez voir offrir de vente le jeu
d'actrice mais regarder le show
l'actrice sabrina et jérôme avoir besoin
de votre analyse là dessus
la ceeac à valence je vous jure sur
twitter les gens réclament une sanction
art à oui mais je peux expliquer non
mais les explications on les a eus mois
voir votre action nous pourrions en
amérique et le caractère mieux fait que
la figure quand même hein mais alors
est-ce que là j'étais contente que
captieux mais vous avez triché avec
quelques invités compris nos batteries
chez vous a été complice est riche et
j'ai laissé faire ce qui est pas pareil
comment est votre mari durer plus
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
capucine et on a d'abord la réaction de
gilles verdez regard qui doit être
nuancée ainsi capucines à tricher c'est
une ronde c'est un scandale tout le
monde voulait un prime - le 1er mai
c'est incroyable je ne laisserai pas
passer ça
capucine je vous mets la note de zéro et
surtout je vous adresse tout le monde
mais prix capucine anna vous êtes une
misérable
[Applaudissements]
sympa alors qu'un piscine à son arme et
je vais vous dire toute la vérité
oui mais c'est vrai bon c'est vrai qu'on
vous fait vachement confiance s'est
réellement passé voilà c'est vrai que
quand vous avez annoncé qu'on allait
gagner un prince c'était mon rêve un
rêve de priver bon voilà 25 ans tous
âges avaient fait par quatre les
parements jérémy ferrari je n'ai pas
volumes dans la rue et je les connais je
vais pas je sais pas je suis allé aux
toilettes et en allant aux toilettes et
je montrais agents les qui regardent les
rushs jeu pas des indépendants autour de
l'étoile
alors alors allez hop avant toilettes il
est vrai que en ce sens vous avez triché
oui ce que je peux finir donc est-ce que
vous avez triché ou non bâchés passé
c'est d'après j'ai entendu une
discussion entre deux personnes qui ont
dit le prime est dans la boîte une alors
je ne savais pas si tôt qu'il avait
triomphé des prix la boîte une et du
coup bah j'en rêvais triché j'ai entendu
mais alors qu'est ce que tu voudrais que
mon nom j'écrivais à isal de près mais
dans le bas cenon sms vous avez lu le fc
metz et vous avez regardé les boisés en
fait monsieur vous ne voulez pas et
c'est tout à votre honneur vous si vous
voulez je n'ai pas dénoncer votre
complice jouer je me permet de rebondir
sur benjamin se restaurer j'aime tout
alla tôt non mais c'est sûr il ya une
taupe naturel regard des hommes alors on
va voir ce qu'on pensait les tweets
hausse regardez on leur a posé une
question etes-vous choqué oui oui non à
37%
quand même mal il ya donc plus besoin
voilà et ben écoute et capucine à
l'école en sachets non mais sachez le il
y aura une sanction programme mais c'est
mérité
non mais je vous le dis durera une
sanction mais j'ai un tout le monde
rêvait du prime donc on est en train de
réfléchir à pour la sélection pour elle
complète demain je ne vais pas dormir la
nuit on et va se réunir avec les équipes
parce que mine de rien il faut mais eva
il faut que vous soyez il faut que vous
y retrouviez ce que vous avez joué vous
avez été biaisé donc forcément les
chroniqueurs on va vous proposer quelque
chose et elle elle sera un truc
fonctionne et un truc qui lui fasse
vraiment mal soixante jours son
épilation entre comme ça
c'est fou on s'en régale c'est fou parce
que moi moi je vous le dis j'ai été un
peu choqué parce que tout le monde le
voulait et c'est vrai que moi la
bombasse et capucine qui a eu le prime
mais vous aurez d'autres choses en fait
on va on va essayer de la lave la banque
va c'était une erreur de la banque en
votre faveur comme dans le monopoly donc
on va vous faire un chèque à chacun ici
voilà un chèque-cadeau de quelque chose
et vous aurez que c'est juste ma
réaction était sincère pourquoi
l'annoncer dans beaucoup de ballons mais
nous aussi on est choqué un pour le
chèque